prévoir phase i 1 2 3 ou la foule
ah oui bah vous qu'on fait ça comprenez
ici sans aller bien
vas-y alexandre 1 2 3
alors je vais te dire hé ben ali daei la
casse tony 1
est-ce que tu suces ton pouce alexandre
s'est promis ça t'a jamais sucé ton
pouce qui mais quand toute la nuit
ah oui et voir comment tu fais
assez drôle ça c'est pas ton pouce que
tu s'user les deux mois du milieu ne
fait pas sa première fois je vois ça tu
ces sifflets tu peux me siffler du cul
oui voilà un garçon complètement complet
alors qu'elle est l'heureux possède sont
tes parents sikila ne doivent pas tant
mais à quoi il ressemble il ressemble à
rien très bien qu est ce que tu nous
champ trop grands maintenant et pas
facile trop grands maintenant temps
comme l'an passé 10 mois deux ans avec
la neige ou verglas ain bessam étrangeté
venette couper l'eau la moitié des
rennais